bonsoir brieuc godefridi merci d'être
avec nous sur rt france ce sont les
présidences qui nomme les juges de la
cour suprême donald trump pendant déjà
nommé 2 pourquoi tant d'indignation le
timing profite certes à donald trump
mais rien ne l'obligeait à temps
d'élections non c'est à dire que là
l'enjeu est considérable non sens où
toutes les grandes questions de société
aux états unis finissent par se résoudre
finalement devant la cour suprême et
donc la majorité républicaine du sénat
parce qu'en réalité le sénat doit
valider le choix du président ce n'est
pas le président tout seul qui décide
la majorité républicaine du sénat elle
ne veut pas prendre le risque de perdre
ladite majorité eux et finalement de
perdre la possibilité de nommer une juge
qui selon toute vraisemblance devrait
être les juges par ex qui a à peine 48
ans et qui pourrait comme l'expliqué
votre sujet à l'instant faire pencher la
balance de la cour suprême vers la
droite républicaine pour un certain
nombre de décennies je dirais à venir
oui parce que les juges sont nommés à
vie
le choix de 2,7 de cette femme c'est ce
qui inquiète les démocrates on sait que
la cour suprême tranche notamment sur
les questions de société de port d'armes
quels sont les enjeux et quelles sont
les décisions prises par la cour suprême
qui compte pour les états unis
je pense que quelques et était le choix
du président américain les démocrates
auraient monté une gigantesque cabale
comme ils l'ont fait à l'époque déjà de
la désignation des juges kavanaugh ils
leur feront ici et donc ils vont trouver
dans le passé dans la personnalité dans
l'identité de la juge parent est si
effectivement ce devait être cette
candidate qui est présenté au sénat
des éléments qui permettent de la
remettre en cause mais ce n'est pas tant
la personnalité d'ailleurs d'une femme
remarquable c'est une femme qui est une
des plus grandes juriste américaine de
cette génération c'est une femme qui a
sept enfants dont cinq biologique un
enfant handicapé deux enfants haïtiens
qu'elle a adoptée et donc quelques et
était la personnalité sur laquelle le
choix du président et de la majorité du
sénat se portent les démocrates ne le
supporte pas parce qu'il ne supporte pas
de perdre le contrôle d'une institution
qu'il contrôle peu ou prou depuis 1945
c'est à dire effectivement la cour
suprême oui il y avait un relatif
équilibre 5,5 juge côté républicain 4
côté démocrate maintenant saffré 6
contre 3 ce serait compliqué par exemple
si joe biden était élu président d'avoir
une cour suprême à majorité républicaine
c'est si effectivement là le juge
barents est désigné par trump et que
monsieur byden devait être élu ce que je
ne crois pas probable mais supposons
effectivement que ce soit le cas et bien
à ce moment là la cour suprême agir est
typiquement comme en contre-pouvoir par
rapport au pouvoir du du président qui
serait dans cette hypothèse en président
démocrate
cela a souvent été le cas dans le passé
où une course où une cour suprême qui
était à l'époque à majorité démocrate a
servi de contre-pouvoir de contrepoids
au pouvoir d'un président républicain je
rappelle l'inca tout de même important
c'est l'art qui roule versus wade qui en
1973 a légalisé l'avortement aux
etats-unis c'est une cour à majorité
démocrate
et maintenant les étages y vivent depuis
un demi siècle sous l'empiré je dirais
de ce jugement
les républicains veulent le retour mais
il est clair que si les juges barrette
qui est une fan de droite qui est une
catholique convaincu devait être désigné
à la cour suprême
les républicains auraient une chance
réelle et véritable de pouvoir en tout
cas remettre le droit à l'avortement
dans des limites plus contraignant que
c'était le cas aujourd'hui donc il
pourrait revenir sur cette décision
effectivement en 2016 de la cour suprême
de légaliser l'avortement
qu'est-ce que ça qu'est ce que ça fait
pour donald trump le fait qu'il juge
admettons la juge barrette ce soir
est-ce que ça va galvaniser comme on le
dit son électorat conservateur religieux
en est il besoin je vous avez tout à
fait raison vous d'abord c'est il est ce
qu'il en a besoin et qui l'élection
présidentielle qui a lieu maintenant
dans une quarantaine de jours donc ça ne
peut effectivement que le service mais
vous avez tout à fait raison
si ce choix devait se confirmer et si
effectivement il parvenait à la sphère
confirmée ensuite par la majorité
républicaine du sénat
ce serait une excellente manière pour le
président américain de galvaniser son
électorat qui dans son écrasante
majorité attend depuis des décennies
littéralement de pouvoir revenir sur un
certain nombre de choses qui ont été peu
à ces extrêmes voire extrémistes qui ont
été décidées
par des majorités démocrates à la cour
suprême avec ici une majorité qui serait
très nettement républicaine très
important également et évidemment il ya
cette bataille des votes par
correspondance ou donald trump dit déjà
que les résultats vont être contestable
on se souvient de l'élection de l'année
2000 george bush contre al gore la cour
suprême avait statué sur les résultats
des élections donc c'est un enjeu
crucial
c'est un enjeu crucial parce que l'ici
donc les démocrates qui sans finalement
qu'il perde à la fois le combat et le
débat démocratique ont tous mis en
oeuvre toute une série d'initiatives au
niveau le cas elles qui ont conduit à
disséminés dans la nature 80 millions ce
qui est considérable évidemment de
bulletins de vote auprès de gens qui
n'avaient pas demandé à voter par
correspondance et donc viala autant de
foyers je dirais de fraudes
considérables sur des échelles qui
pourrait conduire à douter au soir du 3
novembre du résultat de l'élection
présidentielle
hélas de fil en aiguille ce type de
question devrait effectivement être en
dernier en dernière analyse en dernière
instance culturellement tranchée par la
cour s'ouvre par l'aco shoot fans donc
c'est encore un enjeu supplémentaire qui
fait de la désignation éventuelle de la
juge paraît qu une victoire ce serait
une victoire très grande considérable
pour le président américain
on dit aussi souvent que la une dernière
question à drieu godefridi que la cour
suprême
c'est le gouvernement des juges êtes
vous d'accord avec cela
pas du tout ça c'est un fait une
confusion qui vient de ce qu'en france
on des enfants que fait on ne comprend
pas la notion du gouvernement des juges
le guen amandine c'est quand vous avez
des gens qui substitue effectivement à
au jugement de la majorité parlementaire
leur propre jugement ici ce n'est pas de
cela qu'il s'agit ici nous avons un
système de séparation des pouvoirs dans
lequel il y a un très fort très fort
pouvoir présidentiel il ya un fort
pouvoir du congrès donc du parlement
mais il ya également une cour suprême
qui valide et qu'il vérifie en dernière
analyse si les lois qui sont adoptées
par les deux précédentes sont conformes
aux libertés fondamentales qui sont
consacrés je dirais par la constance
des états unis donc ce faisant la cour
suprême fait son métier et ne substitue
pas à son jugement à celui de la
majorité démocratique merci beaucoup
drieu godefridi d'avoir répondu à nos
questions ce soir sur arte france